وسيله الجزيره حصلت على صور لاقمار صناعيه
البارحه من المنطقه الجنوبيه خاصه خانيونس
سنعرضها بعد قليل ونحللها مع اللواء فيس
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي الى
جانب تطورات اخرى اللواء الدويري محمود ما
الذي تم كشفه من خلال هذه الصور التي
التقطت البارحه في خم جلال هذه الصور هي
للرابع من فبراير صور الاقمار الصناعيه
تلتق مساحه
محدده هي كانت في في الجنوب جنوب قطاع غزه
في يونس وهذه الصوره هي في وقت زمني معين
اي اننا يمكن ان نشاهد صوره من عمليات
اليوم كامله خلال تلك الفتره الان كنا
نتحدث دوما عن هذا اللون الاصفر بانه
لحركه الاليات وليس للتوغل التام هذا
يتقاطع مع صور يوم امس في الاقمار
الصناعيه اذا ما شاهدنا هنا هذه هي منطقه
خان يونس ستشاهدون هذا اللون الاصفر
في كامل محيط بمدينه خانيونس اذا ما
اتجهنا بدايه الى هذا هذه الصوره هذه هي
صوره الاقمار الصناعيه هذا هو الشريط الذي
التقطته الاقمار الصناعيه في الرابع من
فبراير وسنلاحظ التالي انظروا الى كل هذا
هذه عمليات تجريف عمليات تجريف سواتر
ترابيه عمليات تجريف سواتر ترابيه هنا
عمليات تجريف وسواتر ترابيه هذه النقطه
وايضا في غرب المدينه طبعا هذا من الملاحظ
فيه انه لم يكن هناك تواجد للاليات لكن
كان هناك استثناء لهذا الوضع وهو في
النقطه التاليه اذا ما توجهنا اكثر اتجاه
الغرب سنشاهد هذا المربع الاحمر هنا في
هذه النقطه هو في شمال مخيم خان يونس لكن
نلاحظ كميه الدمار الكبير الذي لحق بشمال
مخيم مربعات سكنيه كامله سويت تماما تماما
بالارض وتظهرها الاقمار الصناعيه وهذه
الاليات الموجوده هي هنا هي حوالي 23 الى
25 اليه سنشاهدها بشكل اقرب تتمركز في هذا
التجمع السكني سنشاهد هذه الاليات هي هنا
تتجمع على مجموعه من اربعه كذلك في هذه
النقاط هنا كذلك مجموعه من اربعه اذا كنا
نتحدث دوما ان مركز ثقل العمليات في خان
يونس كان هو في غرب المدينه ويكون عمليات
الالتحام كذلك هذا الشارع هو الشارع العام
هذا ما يسمى بالشارع العام ومن الممكن ان
تكون عمليه الضغط باتجاه مدينه خانيونس
تاتي من الغرب باتجاه الشرق مستشفى الامل
الذي دوما ما نتحدث عنه في الاخبار
ومحاولات التوغل من الجهه الغربيه باتجاه
الجهه باتجاه الوسط في خانيونس طبعا هذا
هو هذا من ابرز ما تظهره عمليات او صور
الاقمار الصناعيه لكن اللافت بان اليه
المناورات العسكريه الاسرائيليه اذا ما
شاهدناها هنا سنشاهد
بانها معظم المناطق هذه مره اخرى كانت
خاليه من الاليات خاليه من التوغل العسكري
او عفوا خاليه من التمركز الاليات لكن
يستثنى من ذلك هذه النقطه في غرب خانيونس
مما قد يدل على محاولات الضغط بهذا
الاتجاه طبعا المزيد من التحليل العسكري
سيكون مع معكما جلال ومع اللواء فايز
الدويري عن كيفيه قراءه هذه المناورات
العسكريه وطبعا عندما نشاهد دوما هذا
اللون الاصفر نتحدث عن مناطق الحركه لا
نتحدث عن مناطق التوغل لا نتحدث عن مناطق
التمركز وانما اماكن تحرك الاليات هو
اللفت بان اعداد الاليات تعتبر قليله
مقارنه مع تمركز سابق لقوات الاحتلال لواء
دويري مثلا في الشمال كنا نرصد عبر صور
الاقمار الصناعيه التي تحصل عليها الجزيره
تواجد كبير ومنتشر للاليات هنا نلاحظ في
مربع واحد وربما ليس اكثر من 20 اليه كيف
تفهم على الوقت الذي تم اخذ الصوره فيه لو
كانت الصوره اخذت قبل سته ساعات قد تظهر
حقائق مختلفه لماذا لانه الهجوم بدا على
خان يونس بصوره رئيسيه من الغرب في
جفعاتي وغيره من الالويه المدرعه كان
التركيز بصوره كبيره على منطقه المخيم
جنوب غرب مدينه خاني لحظنا بانه مدمر
بالكامل وفعل فيه ما فعل ولم يستطع ان
يدخل الى عمق المخيم رغم كل ما فعله
فبالتالي اجرى تعديل على المناوره واتجه
باتجاه الشمال هذا ما ما تم تحديده ب 20
23 اليه هذه هي مؤخره القوه لانه القوه
تحركت باتجاه الشمال الغربي لمدينه
خانيونس من منطقه
الصناعه عله يكون هناك
ال الخطه الدفاعيه اضعف منها في منطقه
المخيم المباني المسافات البينيه بينها
اكثر وكذلك الجهه الشماليه من منطقه
القراره والدخول الى حي الامل لم يستطع ان
يحقق ذلك رغم فائض القوه الذي استخدم ورغم
الاحاطه التي جاءت من الف وي الى قزان
النجار الان وزير الدفاع اشار في قبل قليل
بانه يحتاج
الى اسبوع عم عمل في قال بان كتيبه
خانيونس
تنهار يعني هكذا هكذا قال يعني
فكك كتيبه خان يونس يقول هو في الواقع
يوجد لواء خان يونس وليس كتيبه عدد كتائب
وغير معروف توجد قوات النخبه من
الفصائل تغطيته ل منطقه العمليات من
السياج حتى شارع الرشيد وبالتالي يعتبر هو
اللواء الاقوى هكذا يقال واللواء الاكثر
تمرسا في القتال فلا اعتقد ان كلام وزير
دفاع جيش الاحتلال واقعي او قريب من
الواقع لاحظ محمود الكثير من السواتر
الترابيه مثل هنا مثل هناك اعداد كبيره من
السواتر الترابيه في الشمال اللواء
الدويري كنا نلاحظ دائما سواتر ترابيه
واليات تتمركز في هذه المنطقه
و هذه قلت لك هذه تعكس الواقع الميداني في
لحظه اخذ الصوره لو اخذت قبل يوم او يومين
يمكن ان تظهر لك العديد من الاليات هذه
السواتر الترابيه التي يعملها هي من اجل
تامين الحمايه هو توقف في هذه المنطقه هو
توقف قصير الامد لان هناك مجريات معركه
القوات التي تقاتل تقات هجوم يسمى هجوم
بالعمق يكون على شكل على شكل احزمه
متتاليه وبالتالي الوحدات الخلفيه لا
تستطيع ان ان تبقى مكشوفه خاصه انه طبيعه
المنطقه والانفاق تم تمنح المقاتل من
كتائب القسام وغيرها الى الخروج والمفاجاه
فهي تحمي انفسها بسواتر ترابيه تؤمن ما
يطلق عليه البدن المخفي للاليات لكن نحاول
ان نفهم اكثر هل من الممكن بان الاليات
تتوجه من الشريط الحدودي او منطقه غلاف
غزه تقوم بما تسميها قوات الاحتلال مناوره
عسكريه وتعود من ثم هل هذا امن بالنسبه
لها يعني الان هو في البدايه كان الجهد
الرئيسي من المنطقه الشرقيه ووصل العدد
الى ثمانيه الويه زج منها لوائين من منطقه
القراره مدينه الحمد
وحتى المخيم دفع
ب لواء ناقص او مجموعه قتال من جنوب خزاعه
باتجاه خزان النجار فعمل على فكي كماشه
لكن الجهد الرئيسي لم يستطع ان يحقق
انجازات في منطقه عبسان وبن سيلا وزنه
فحول لهذا الجهد من جهد رئيسي متعثر الى
جهد ثانوي ونقل معظم القوه لتعزيز الهجوم
في منطقه مدينه مدينه خان يونس لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه
يعني الدخول الى عمق المدينه لا يزال ليس
بذلك العمق الذي يمكن من الوصول الى قلب
المدينه وتحدثنا قبل يومين عن اهميه حي
الامل بالنسبه ل لاسرائيل تعتبره اولويه
بهذه المرحله لانها تقول او تعتقد بان
قيادات حماس في الجنوب تتواجد هناك وربما
ايضا عدد من المحتجزين يعني الان حي الامل
سيقود مباشره الى قلب المدينه الى المركز
المدينه وبالتالي التوقع وهذه تصريحات اي
قراناها في اكثر من موقع محسوب على الكيان
انه يتوقع ان القياده ذات الرئيسيه
السياسيه والعسكريه والرهائن يتواجدوا في
هذه المنطقه هذا ما يعتقدونه على الرغم
انه قد يكون الواقع مختلف كليا ومناقض
كليا لهذه التوجهات انت اشرت الى تصريحات
وزير الدفاع ربما كانت هي الاطول والاكثر
تفصيلا عن سير المعارك والاكثر حده ربما
في التعاطي مع مجريات المعركه عندما يقول
بان كتيبه خانيونس على وشك الانهيار بان
اسرائيل قد على تقريبا 50% من مقاتلي حماس
بان القدره القتاليه
وتجنيد مقاتلين جدد خاصه في الشمال غير
ممكنه كيف تفهم تفهم كل هذه التصريحات في
ظل الواقع الذي ربما لا يعكس ما يقوله
يعني هو هو يتحدث بما يشاء وسيعود ويناقض
نفسه كما تحدث قال تم القضاء على وتفكيك
البنيه التنظيميه
لقوات القسام في القاطع الشمال مالي عاد
بعدها بعده ايام وقال ان جيوب المقاومه من
الصعب جدا القضاء عليها اذا هو يدلي
بتصريحات حسب الظرف السياسي والموقف
السياسي وبالتالي
هو الان اسمه امام محكمه لاهاي وامام
محكمه مجرمي الحرب وبالتالي هو يراهن على
شيء ما وكذلك يعني لا لا يغرك انه تقاربه
او هو الاقرب الى نتنياهو ولكن كلاهما
يتنافس مع الاخر للمقالات ما بعد الحرب
تصريحاته لا تعكس الواقع وانا اخذ من
تصريحاته في القاطع الشمالي واسقطها على
القاطع الجنوبي طيب اذا توجهنا اكثر جنوبا
وانا قبل اسبوع تقريبا اثرت معك هذه
النقطه موضوع منطقه رفح والتي اصبحت اليوم
يعني حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقول
بان اعداد كبيره من النازحين يقبعون في
هذه النقطه في رفح وبالتالي يجب ان يكون
او يتعامل معها الجيش الاسرائيلي بخصوصيه
وبحساسية
اسرائيل تتحدث عن عن نزوح عكسي الى الشمال
اوكي ان النزوح العكسي كان كان القرار
واضح يحتاج الى قرار سياسي وهذا القرار
السياسي لم يصدر اذا لا يوجد قرار سياسي
بالسماح بالعوده والقناصين في هذا اليوم
كم عدد القتلى في منطقه في المنطقه
الشماليه
الان الطرح الاخر ان يذهبوا الى خان يونس
بعد انتهاء معارك خان يونس معركه خان يونس
لم تنتهي ولا لن تنتهي خلال اسبوع
واسبوعين كما تحدث وزير الدفاع هذه لا
تزال معضله ثم يبقى موقف موقف مصر اين مصر
مما سيجري هل سترزق لي طلبات نتنياهو ام
ستبقى مصر العروبه والتاريخ اسرائيل تتحدث
عن ترتيبات مع الجانب المصري كيف تفهم يا
سيدي هذه الترتيبات اصلا ضبابيه مدير
الشيم بيت ذهب الى يقال ذهب الى مصر واجرى
مفاوضات ولكن يعني لابد ان يكون هناك موقف
مصري واضح لانه بكل بساطه يعني مصر
بتاريخها بحجمها بعدد سكانها يجب ان يكون
لها موقف وبالتالي ان نتنياهو ان يفرض على
مصر شيء هذا امر خارج المنطق بالنسبه
للاداره المصريه الواء دويري حصلت الجزيره
على مشاهد جلله تظهر استهداف كتائب القسام
لاليه الاحتلال المتوغلة
الياسين
105 نشاهد هذه الصوره يحمل معولا هو يعمل
على تحضير لحشوه يحفر يضع الحشوه ومن ثم
احنا هنا من زاويه واحده يعني الان يحفر
يضع الحشوه عندما تاتي الدبابه يفجر هذه
الحشوه وتنفجر حشوه اخرى لم يتم تصويرها
اثناء اثناء تجهيزها سيكون التفجير مزدوج
تفجير عبر كيبل ولا تفجير بغض النظر قد
تكون لا كان في فاصل زماني فاصل زماني
فاصل زمني خفيف لانه لو كان التوصيل
بالكورت سيكون اني مباشره ولكن الفصل زمني
يعني بانه كان يعني يقاس
بالثواني وقت واضح اللقطه هذه هو داخل
المنزل يسدد يفتح الباب جزئيا ويسدد على
دبابه
و نتيجه التفجير كانت
واضحه هذا استهداف لاليه اثر استهداف رتل
من الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه دائما
القسام هذه بقايا بقايا الدبابه التي تم
لافت لواء دويري وانت تذكرها دائما بان
القسام تبرز عمليه الاستهداف وما بعد
عمليه الاستهداف على عكس الجيش الا هي
تصور ما
تم الحدث الرئيسي يصور بصوره كامله هذه
مركاه نعم ودائما الاستهداف من اعلى نلاحظ
لانه نتيجه الضربه بتكون مؤث
اكثر نقطه ارتطام القذيفه مهمه جدا
بالنسبه للتحصينات والمدرعات التي تتمتع
بها الاليات العسكريه كذلك يعني انا
شاهدته هذا الفيلم يوجد فيه كمان استهداف
جرافه واستهداف عربه النمر ا و ئ كان
تقريبا خمس خمس لقطات كان في خانيونس هذه
معارك غرب خانيونس هذه دي 9 على ما يبدو
نعم جرافه الدي 9 انا قلت لك انه كانت
فيها عربه النمر وجراف دينا وثلا هذه من
كافا ايضا ايضا من الاستهداف من نقطه
مرتفعه
نعم اذا التوغل الاليات في في اماكن ما
زال ما زال البناء بها موجود هي يعتبر خطر
بالنسبه لاي لاي جيش صح نعم الان يعني
امكانيه الاختفاء وامكانيه التسديد
المباشر وخط النظر يكون ايسر من المكان
على من بين الردم وبالتالي هنا يعطي فرصه
وتاني للراصد لينفذ عمليته بمنتهى الدقه
طيب الواء دويري اريد ان اختم معك بما
يحصل في المنطقه بشكل عام كسؤال اخير
التطورات في اليمن التهديد الاسرائيلي
المتكرر لجنوب لبنان وللبنان بشكل عام في
حال استمرت
المعارك هل هل هل يتغير شيء على الساحه
حتى هذه اللحظه لا رغم التهديدات بالنسبه
لل يعني تصريحاتهم واضحه جدا حتى لو توقف
حزب الله عن استهداف
لاكون الحرب محتمله حتى يطبق 17 اعتقد هذا
كلام لتسويق السياسي المحلي لكن الان
المقاومه
الاسلاميه لها تاثير بغض النظر عن حجمه
والانصار الله الحوثيين فرضوا واقع معين
وبالتالي لا اقول وحده ساحات
بالمعنى المطلق لكن هناك تعاون ما بين هذه
الساحات شكرا اللواء فيز زويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وسيله نعود اليك
لمتابعه هذه التغطيه المستمره للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه شكرا جزيلا